this was my reminder to wish my mom
happy birthday on Monday I forgot it's
tuna steak here on it's Grayson it's
time to talk back to you so let's start
on tumblr alliteration can't spell
alliteration without mommy new person to
person person Tommy I don't know a new
person comments on some of my social
media platforms I praise the crap of
them and welcome to the its grace family
where we do rituals tiny fun cult mom
read more like that's what I called
mamrie for a year before she corrected
me and told me this actually pronounced
mamrie so that's really racist your
stupid student council is making me late
for grace being on TV don't do
extracurricular skits I mean do
extracurriculars if you want to what are
you a student council are you president
cool vice president best job ever
excellent title you do jack [ __ ]
secretary not really well respected
treasurer you are not actually doing
money things you're a nice girl but who
wants to run for treasurer it does have
a word treasure in it love treasures
Holy Trinity a new person to person to
person Holy Trinity more like day five
you're all very bad at spelling you my
heart is gone potato I can't take this I
actually squeal to my family looked at
me rather oddly that's good because as
far as I know or can assume you are not
a pig that has learned to use tumblr so
squealing would cause concern because
that's not your normal sound unless you
are a pig that's learned to use tumblr
in which case how have you not named
yourself now let's go over to Twitter
another social media platform jananam to
person to person to person Jenna no more
like Jen
I know about Nando's remember then iPod
nanos their sound is so cute and they're
so tiny and I was like I'm gonna Lenny
this object if I own it
oh look at you go grace helbig on the
boob tube again why does it call it the
boob tube
I bet it's called boob tube because it's
like you really just want to see it
fives a brave new person to person 2005
so brave you were like 5 so bread love
bread I wish that we needed oxygen water
and bread to survive cuz that would just
feel like really cool to have to eat
bread to stay alive I don't care who you
are grace Helbig is better than you know
mm-hmm have you heard of Usain Bolt
YouTube's new person to person to person
youtube more like boobs boobs you are
essentially my boss and I just called
you for those boobs can you guess which
one Direction's song Chester C and grace
Helbig are covering here according to
this photo I think we're covering please
stop touching my face let's go to
YouTube or as most people will prefer to
it boom boom the sheep that went Moo new
person to person to person the sheep
that went move more like that's not
correct and if a sheep did go Moo and
congratulations that sheep is bilingual
buell Devery was happily watching
another grace video blissfully unaware
that it will be my last for a while you
can't just do that grace suddenly I'm
cold turkey where will I get my next fix
do they sell grace videos on the black
market I'm not gonna make it [ __ ]
there's like a lot of bad that happens
in other countries that is like
sincerely bad also used to live cool
like and subscribe James chats new
person to person to person James chats
more like James shouts pants
because he just wants everyone in the
room to feel like a better sense of
themselves because they didn't do that
you know she's taking a week off in
preparation of saying yes to my prom
proposal
hashtag dream big yes I did James see
that you have asked me to go to prom
with you are you in college does college
um prompts Ozone you're not in college
and you're in high school you're asking
to go to your prom I felt like that's
like illegal right how old are you
when is your prom I'm really bad at
grinding though and that would be like a
big part of prom probably Ryan Lamont
you person to person to person Brian
Lamont more like Ryan laments all the
time because he's toast
grace they need to get you on the red
carpet at one of these events one day
you can review outfits live no I review
fashion on the internet because I would
be very uncomfortable saying it to that
person's face always talk behind
people's backs don't do that I'm doing
that oh gosh moral conundrum
oh maybe that would be my stripper name
well there you go there's all for
talking back to you stay off the you
enjoyed your time here in this little
niche of the internet I don't know don't
worry they can prove it on my book and
graces guide book calm that was my shoe
I did fart did you even hear that
no I'm drawing attention to it Oh